the New York City Police Department is
beta-testing or as I like to call it
master beta testing Google glass
yeah master use that joke like a
thousand times on Twitter it doesn't get
any retweets
yeah the NYPD's massive and
controversial intelligence analytics
unit is evaluating whether Google glass
is a good fit for investigating
terrorists and helping cops make arrests
we've got a quote from a New York City
law enforcement official we signed up
got a few pairs of the Google glasses
and we're trying them out seeing if they
have any value in investigations mostly
for patrol purposes we're looking at
them you know seeing how they work I
think the best part of that is he calls
them the Google glasses which is like
talking about the Facebook and the
Twitter and the kids and all that stuff
wireless facial recognition software it
could help match suspects name and faces
to information contained databases that
law-enforcement agencies use and it
could help eliminate the time-consuming
handwritten or typed reports by enabling
video recording and dictation for
digital reports we've talked a lot about
Google glass here I truly believe if
this thing takes off the way it sounds
like it will it's gonna fundamentally
change how we react to each other and
pretty much every interaction that
humans have why because we're all gonna
be constantly you guys are already
wearing glasses and once they can put
the chip in there and I won't even know
whether you're recording me or what
you're looking at some you can see
everything you need to know about me at
the same time and you can record me and
you know the applicant all the sex stuff
which we've been talking about I talked
about this the other week on Joe Rogan's
podcast and I got so many responses on
Twitter have you guys seen this amazing
UK show called black mirror no its first
of all it's so good let me tell
everybody on YouTube you need to check
this out it's so good there's only six
episodes so you'll be really
disappointed if you download them all
and batch watch them because they're
amazing but it's it's this very
dystopian very cool kind of futuristic
show and one of the episodes is about a
future and not too far in the few that
swai the show so brilliant they make
technology they integrate it seamlessly
where everybody has what they call the
grain implant is behind their ear and
they can recall everything they
did in their lives it's basically just
their memories on a hard drive and so
they can use a little remote and they
can rewatch the past and they do such a
beautiful job of showing how it does
fundamentally change the way that people
interact with each other what people do
for fun
how how levels of trust are built
between people and I think that's why
this is such an interesting and
important story for the NYPD because
coming out of the huge stop and frisk
controversy with de Blasio basically
putting the kibosh on that and moving
forward into this new area where we're
seeing in LA that they're trying out
these lapel cams which i think is such a
brilliant step forward for civil
liberties let's make sure that we are
always recording what the police are
doing so long as we can have access to
those videos I think that that is going
to be very important for the civil
rights and civil liberties of people
that they are putting into custody of
people that they are questioning I think
that this could actually be good for the
person on the other side of it she spun
it positively as opposed to just the
cops watching us all the time which I
think none of us want isn't this going
to be a combo of like Minority Report
and Total Recall I'm on a movie I don't
know man I don't first of all if we get
to the point where you could put them in
designer glasses and buy designer glass
I just mean the glasses that people
would choose to you can get your
prescription lenses in them now as long
as people had to wear that when they
appear now there's no chance of it
happening yeah it's just that's not you
started looking better imagine just your
glasses with a little thing stuck on it
right there that's pretty much all of it
well I mean from an investigative tool
for police wearing them out to me it
doesn't that doesn't and my initial
reaction and I was slow on the NSA so
maybe I'm slow on this I mean I came
around on the NSA so have you back on an
Ivy Police Department is I can't believe
what they did like this you apologies
for half the things you say before him
and now you're issuing a pre retraction
yeah I mean in a year I'm gonna be like
I'm traveling to his back instead it's a
great place
I'm gonna go to the beach if there is
one - can totally write in the purpose
of those dashcams
is to help us write the dashcams are
there so that the cops can't beat the
[ __ ] out of us you know as Chappelle
said sprinkle some crack on them and run
off right so I think that this is
actually really important being able to
quickly get the information Moberly that
you know download guys prior or mean you
know anything that makes police work you
know again that's just that that most of
this seems like progress the only part
that doesn't is our people being spied
on without them knowing final thought on
this forgetting the legislation and the
legal stuff forgetting that side just
the human part of it I was at Home Depot
this weekend and I bought something at
the self checkout aisle and now at the
self checkout aisle they have a camera
on you the entire time with all these
warnings are being recorded and under
that and I was thinking it there is this
moment of like did I do something wrong
did I steal something I didn't steal
anything
I find a freaking big box couldn't
install it even if I want to but people
have stolen things that they had to put
that in place okay so I get I understand
why they do it but but there was this
moment where I'm looking at this camera
oh he was showing me a monitor recording
me so I could watch it record myself and
I thought for a moment this is this is
the future we are constantly going so
just what do you guys think about just
the human side of it forget the law part
just the idea that that is going to just
exist I think there's a trade-off I
think when it comes to privacy
it's about privacy and convenience and
you can almost never have both at the
same time the more that we give up our
privacy oftentimes the more we have
these conveniences it's the same reason
that there's a camera on the ATM and I
feel safer knowing that there's a camera
on my ATM then unsafe I was in Europe
last spring really for the first time in
forever and you know they the cameras
everywhere
everywhere I mean it's it every every
corner you look up we need you if if
your point is to see the cameras in
Europe you're stunned at how many
cameras there are so they've been living
with that for a while and of course when
those you know I still think of those
cameras as recording video the way it
would have in 1988 you know it's in like
only in 24 can they be like the zoom in
on that make that clear they're like you
know it looks like this and all the
sudden like holy [ __ ]
so like but of course it's already
everywhere I mean you know it's not hard
to trace people's actions just if
they're out in many many many
neighborhoods and that's what I get back
to is that nonsense like we just we've
almost I guess it's not too late but
we've blown an opportunity to get to be
talking about it before we're reacting
to it before we've got a government that
says you're gonna take this away from us
do you know why we haven't been attacked
in five years because we've been doing
this and then we're like oh well I don't
want to be I don't want to be a real
difficulty because there is a lot of
kind of clandestine stuff happening it's
hard for us as the as the citizens to
know exactly where we're being protected
and where we're being abused and I think
it's a really fine line and it's a line
that we're gonna be walking the rest of
our lives and it's something that we
have to be really aware of and be
engaged in the political process so that
we can make sure that that fine line
stays where it is well what is very
clear is we can't just trust them we
can't solely trust them so I get it
they're gonna do it I want them to do it
I want them to do a lot of protecting
point and well they can't just decide on
their own I don't not trust these guys
instinctively the way I some do like
most people working at the NRC
but you know what I mean the NSA they're
they're trying they want to keep us safe
they're not like we got these new toys
in this money that's but some but I mean
but you know either it's irrelevant to
me what they're what's in their head
what's necessary is to have an
independent judicial panel with real
independence and real teeth go no not
you can't do that one you have no
evidence to do that that's all yeah so
we have that all we can do it is think
about it and talk about it and there you
go